ce matin-là il pleut et les chevaux sont
l'objet de soins attentifs on va jusqu'à
leur permirent les sabots un peu pour
que la boue ne s'y accroche pas un peu
par tradition d'élégance le prince
philippe at elle toujours lui même
casquette trench coat style gentleman
farmer il pleut disait jamais la pluie
fait partie des richesses d'éternel de
l'angleterre dans le pays du thé l'eau a
même quelque chose de respectable pour
le prince comme pour ses chevaux il
s'agit aujourd'hui surtout d'un
entraînement de maniabilité le
championnat au pain dans quinze jours
comprendra d'autres épreuves encore
notamment d'endurance mais l'essentiel
est de ne pas forcer des chevaux tout en
sentant au bout des reines qu'ils sont
déjà en condition physique
nous sommes à windsor devant le
formidable château construit par edouard
iii
il y a 6 ans en premier exercice il
s'agit de faire faire à l'attelage une
sorte de slalom entre les plots jaunes
et voyait avec l placidité ces animaux
obéissent ce que philippe leur demande
de faire sans rien perdre de leur camp
pas soit c'est que depuis azincourt les
chevaux anglais qui vont en france se
doivent de garder un certain sentiment
de supériorité mais oui les valets de
pied sont anglais eux aussi la preuve
après les plots jaunes un gay profond
l'homme doit rassurer d'attelage
mais comment le prince est il
sélectionner ses chevaux pour le
championnat d'europe et bien parmi les
serviteurs attitré et habituel de l'état
s'endette ou le même couleur ne peut pas
tout le monde grandeur n'est pour nous
ils sont tous les chevaux qui font le
travail de l'état de la loi est assez
grand pour porter le grand audard mais
oui est ce que vous allez prendre part
comme concurrent dans le championnat
d'europe je voudrais bien mais vous ne
savez donc pas si vous serez sélectionné
ici débarrasser des airs mais chaque
matin ces chevaux pendant des semaines
viennent s'entraîner oubliant des
chevauchées officiel et leur carrosse
des processions d'apparat l'image
symbolique du siècle au dessus de la
tamise paisible l'avion à réaction qui
d'ailleurs ne gêne nullement ses chevaux
habitué aux clips qui les paiera montons
près de notre haute mer les chevaux
comprennent t-il ce que vous voulez
c'est une combinaison de bois de rennes
de circonstance
[Musique]
le faut être me faut
un peu de tout mais le vois plutôt parce
qu'ils composent et comment comprenez
vous ce qu'ils veulent et ce qu'ils ne
veulent pas s'y colle
on va faire une analyse de chaque cheval
tout le temps un peu l'autre français
qu'est ce qu'il pense qu'est ce qu'il
pense et à quelque chose là qu'il n'aime
pas et celui là nous ça il veut tourner
ici on doit analyser les pensées de tous
de chaque phrase tout le temps aux
toutes dernières nouvelles le prince
philippe malgré ses doutes vient mais
oui d'être sélectionné dans l'équipe
britannique
il sera donc au pain sa double qualité
de président de la fédération équestre
et de concurrents mais s'ils gagnent
l'attelage à quatre
comment va-t-il faire pour se remettre
la coupe à lui même il va falloir qu'il
se coupe en quatre
[Musique]